ah ouais je suis dévasté Viateur la
marche est âgé de 84 ans il y a encore
deux ans il était à l'emploi de
l'entreprise familiale propane la
fortune où il a passé près de 18 ans
vous voyez bon bonne
moi
que ça pouvait un jour arriver après
avoir entendu l'explosion hier matin il
a tout de suite tenté de joindre par
téléphone l'une des employés et elle a
répondu parce que avec son cellulaire
cet employé qu'il connaît très bien est
l'une des trois personnes qui manquent à
l'appel c'est une femme qui était
vraiment tranquille qui disait pas un
mot
le travail d'expertise de la scène va
durer plusieurs jours sur le site de
l'explosion les policiers travaillent
sans relâche même si la neige complique
les recherches c'est envisager comme
demain on érige même un chapiteau pour
protéger l'intégrité de la scène en
matinée le ministre François Bonnardel
s'est rendu sur les lieux de la tragédie
pour constater les dégâts
si la communauté ici musulmane vous avez
besoin de quoi que ce soit le
gouvernement sera présent Isabelle
Lafortune ne copropriétaire de
l'entreprise c'est également adressée
aux médias dans un message rempli
d'émotions ce n'est pas extrêmement
difficile pour nous c'est une première
en 67 ans
l'enquête va nous permettre d'en
apprendre davantage et nous allons
continuer de collaborer avec les
autorités
on n'a rien qui nous pointe vers la voie
criminelle ou suspecte mais je peux pas
m'avancer davantage c'est très difficile
qui se vit actuellement parce qu'il y a
de l'attente